before we go here is one thing you can
do today to live a happier healthier and
more productive life it's part of our
partnership with Gretchen Rubin and her
award-winning podcast happier a new
study by MIT found 50% of the US
workforce is working remotely and with
62% of summer camps closed being a
parent and working from home can be a
huge challenge for some families I would
say all New York Times bestselling
author Gretchen Rubin joins us from her
home in New York City with tips on
sharing parenting duties and workspaces
during the pandemic
good morning Gretchen how can this be
done well you know it's not easy one of
the things to think about is now that
we're working from home we have more
flexibility with our schedules a lot of
us so if you have a morning person and a
night person really lean into that and
let the morning person do the chores
like getting getting everything going in
the morning when they're high-energy and
let the night person handle the end of
the day when maybe they're still feeling
more energetic and that morning person's
really dragging take advantage of those
natural energy levels all right Gretchen
but what if you are single and you don't
have the luxury of splitting chores or
keeping up with a partner's energy great
thing a lot of people do is virtual
babysitting this is what a grandparent
or another you know loving adult will
virtually babysit and so maybe they'll
read a story to a child over zoom or
they'll let the child put on a show
would tell or put on the show and so
they're under the watchful eye of an
adult while the other adult is working
in another room
it keeps the child occupied and happy
and with an adult's eye on them you know
I had a friend back in the day whose
father whenever he was reading the
newspaper that was the signal do not
disturb you say do not despair periods
are really important well yes because if
we need to focus if we need to have an
important phone call we need do not
disturb and so if you're working in a
family where there are a lot of people
around you need to make it very clear
when you need to be undisturbed and one
of the things that might help is to
rethink the work hours in the week maybe
you're gonna work in the evening maybe
you're gonna work over the weekend so
that more there's more flexibility in
when you might
get that do not disturb time for that
really high focus intensity time that we
all need yeah and if you can't get it
from putting a newspaper up you can put
Elmo on almost a terrific babysitter in
my household from time to time Gretchen
Rubin thank you very much we appreciate
it